when it
comes to the best villains in the story
two names are almost
always on the table doflamingo and
crocodile
however who of the two is actually the
better villain
i think there can only be one clear
choice here
however there's actually a lot more to
this question
than you might think and so what i want
to discuss with you today
is why doflamingo is the better villain
and why that's actually not a bad thing
for crocodile
at all now you might or might not agree
with this statement and so i recommend
you watch this video until the very end
so you know what i really mean by that
oh yeah and before we get into it if you
haven't subscribed
to the channel yet make sure to hit that
big red button
below this video
if you are interested in storytelling
even just a little
you will know that within the long
lasting format of one piece
oda has been referencing events themes
and symbols from before the time skip
after the crew has reached a new world
basically on a constant basis
fishman island references arlen park
punk hazard mirror strum island
and then we come to dressrosa
what does this arc and the main
protagonist mirror from the first part
of the story
one of my favorite parallels in the
series is an extraordinarily similar
scene shared by doflamingo and anil
as my good friend mr morge explains in
one of his
fantastic videos there are actually some
interesting similarities between anil
and doffy
as both of them have a serious god
complex
ruling in tyranny over the people in the
belief that they stand above everyone
else
and ultimately both of them are taken
down by god's natural enemy
luffy and i definitely agree with this
parallel and believe that oda has
integrated parts of anil into dophi
however going not only by the order of
pre-timeskip arcs
but also by the vast number of parallels
between the two
the main inspiration for dress rose and
doflamingo
was without any doubt alabasta
and yes no one else than crocodile
himself in fact the list of similarities
between the two warlords is
so long that i will move through it
fairly quickly here
not to make this video unnecessarily
long
let's start with the more obvious
parallels and then move a bit deeper
on the most basic level both the second
saga of pre-time skip
alabaster and the second saga of
post-time skip dresrosa
are about a kingdom that is suffering
under the rule of one of the shichibukai
one controlled by a crocodile and the
other by a flamingo
going with the animal theme of the
warlords also
if you're like me and for some reason
have completely missed this super
obvious theme until now
here's a quick overview crocodile is a
crocodile
doflamingo is a flamingo mihawk is a
hawk
kuma literally means bear in japanese
hancock is of course a boa constrictor
jimbei means whale shark in japanese
and finally gekkomoria has actually two
animals
there's obviously the gecko but putting
his name together
gekkomoria komori actually means bat in
japanese
there if you weren't aware of that fact
yet now you know
getting back to topic the flamingo and
crocodile share
a lot more than just a superficial theme
both were the leaders of powerful
criminal organizations
with a number of devil fruit users
including a bomber
someone who can change their weight
someone who can turn their body into
weapons
a power related to art and someone who
can move freely underground
both the baroque works as well as the
donkey hut family have themed code names
one with numbers the other with playing
cards
as a result both mr zero and joker
operated under the facade of celebrated
heroes in their respective countries
committing dark dealings that
contributed to the country's
deterioration
both were trading illegal substances as
part of this scheme
dance powder and sad and both of them
have mastered the devil fruit powers to
high levels able to severely distort the
surrounding environments
both of them at first seemed to get
decapitated
crocodile by vivi and dophi by curos
however both of them easily avoid any
harm by displaying their full skills
oh yeah and for some weird reason both
of them also seem to have a thing for
draped furry coats
but this is far from all let's move to a
more personal level now
even from a plot and character
perspective the flamingo
is clearly referencing crocodile
storyline
first of all both were present at
roger's funeral
being inspired to advance their efforts
to reach the top of the pirate world
both aim to do so by first establishing
control over an entire country
however both of them also earned the
scorn of the country's princess
both vivi and viola went undercover in
their respective organizations
to oppose their evil schemes and protect
their fathers
king cobra and king riku both flamingo
and crocodiles see their subordinates as
tools to advance their own goals
this can be seen especially well in how
they treat those who do not perform well
enough
crocodile completely disregarded galdino
and doflamingo lost any interest
whatsoever in bellamy
after his failure against luffy
exploiting his admiration for him
and i think we can take this all the way
to their respective conflicts with luffy
because in both cases it needed luffy to
uncover their true face
and liberate the country from the
tyranny at first
both crocodile and dophi seem superior
to luffy
and in both cases luffy manages to take
them out in the end
anyway also as a quick side note the way
that luffy destroys doflamingo's string
clone
is very similar to crocodile's defeat as
they both are sent
up to the ceiling and were beaten up by
an attack which involves luffy punching
them multiple times
until the ceiling gets destroyed as they
fall to the ground
and ultimately both of them not only
lost their status as warlords
but also ended up in level 6 of impul
down
as you can see the parallels between
both villains are
endless and i think it should be
self-evident that doflamingo
is strongly inspired by crocodile's role
pre-time skill
so now you might say well if doflamingo
is just a copy of crocodile
doesn't that really make crocodile the
better villain so
let's talk about why i think that
doflamingo is superior here from a
storytelling perspective
the most fundamental assumption here is
that good writers
improve over the course of their career
they learn
what works what doesn't how to structure
things better
and how to improve their characters and
while for most authors this will happen
over the course of multiple books
screenplays and stories oda has been
writing the same storyline for over
20 years and so all of his trial and
error
as well as all of his experience and
improvement are visible throughout the
same story
and so as a direct result of this i
think that oda made it a point
to revisit alabasta that was already
great
and wanted to prove that he can make it
even a little bit better
a similar setting but better
a similar story but better
now this doesn't mean in any way that i
dislike alabaster even in the slightest
just the opposite the fact that
alabaster was
such a fantastic saga was the thing that
made dressrosa
what it is in the first place also as
one big caveat here i'm strictly talking
about the manga
the anime adaptation of dressrosa was in
my personal opinion
way worse than the manga while the anime
did really well with alabaster
now that being said drastirosa is woven
way better into the overall flow of the
story and the overarching events
than alabaster did once that story was
over
it basically felt a little bit like a
hard cut
similarly dresrosa integrates many of
the major themes of the story
just a little bit better than alabasta
does
for example the helplessness of the
marines in dressrosa
has way more weight and fujitora's
experience with luffy
happens on a more fundamental level i
think than with smoker
whose transition happens over a longer
period of time
even an admiral could do nothing in the
face of the warlord system
but in the end fujitora actually
abolished it
but moving on to the villains themselves
i think it's great that oda made
doflamingo
what crocodile actually aspired to be
crocodile wanted to gain control over
the country
and build his power from there
doflamingo actually
managed to do so he completely overthrew
the king
and drooled openly
as a result i think that in the final
moments of both
battles the position of luffy and the
villain
are extremely important to the symbolism
of the arc
and theme against crocodile luffy is
below him and defeats him by
punching him up into the sky revealing
him as the crook and monster that he was
to all of alabasta
by literally throwing him into the light
luffy being below him during the final
moments represents luffy's climb and
eventual triumph over crocodile
as the underdog recovering from his
previous losses
it's a true struggle for luffy to punch
crocodile into the open and through
bedrock
further symbolizing the barrier
crocodile has created to protect himself
from the public
now luffy versus doflamingo on the other
hand completely
contrasts this luffy is now above the
villain
symbolically representing that luffy is
now the one with the upper hand
doflamingo has already been revealed to
the country of dressrosa
as the monster he is and so they're
fighting in the sky
and being watched by everyone on the
island
luffy's final attack against dophie is a
complete stomp
with not much that can be done to stop
it the
ground underneath them being demolished
is symbolic of the foundation of lies
that the country was built upon being
crushed
this change of position is further
symbolized in the techniques that luffy
uses to defeat them
luffy defeat a crocodile single attack
with a storm of punches
while doflamingo's many-phased attack
was broken through with
one huge punch
i think it's clear that these two scenes
are meant to mirror each other
and so once again oda uses all the good
he did with crocodile
to enhance doflamingo and so i think
that both crocodile
and doflamingo are fantastic characters
however i think that dophi is superior
in the sense that oda was able to build
on
improve and expand what he did with
crocodile
in addition to all of that i also think
that doflamingo's character overall
is one of the most complex in the story
so far
so if you want to learn more about that
i recommend that you check out my
character analysis on him here
thanks guys peace